movie opens with 30 seconds of
post-apocalyptic landscape form late
yeah totally I mean in a
post-apocalyptic world everything runs
on a strict schedule to maze to runner
wow we could own several airships they
chose to transport their virus immune
saviors by train you know because those
are way less probable than airplanes
hey what me know was taken by wicked at
the end of the Scorch Trials back to
their base for harvesting was he doing
on this train other than bloating the
run time at the end of the Scorch Trials
Thomas told everybody he was going to
save me no but when they asked if he had
a plan the movie cut to the credits
because quite clearly he did not so I
guess the plan was let's hope wicked
uses trains to transport people so we
can rob not only the train but Fast Five
pay for it why didn't they just use our
plane to transport the kids in the first
place
how am I supposed to know Bob wicked
pays me in tequila shots Poli how did
you get promoted two tequila shots I've
been here longer than you
networking Bob now listen also why
wasn't the plane flying along with the
train in the first place if we could
thought to have the security in place if
needed why not have it closer to the
actual thing it's protecting well the
credits say this character's name is
Vince I'm pretty sure the script calls
him doubting Thomas right now make my
way to the firing squad now also we've
had two movies and Counting with
characters saying like this two or about
Thomas yet they keep following this
kid's direction even though he's never
once really proved himself to be capable
of anything other than getting people
killed or kidnapped how does this work
exactly without Vince behind the wheel
keeping the car steady that would be
zigzagging all over the train track
seriously Thomas is the fucking worst so
Vince diesel is now either dead or has
zero skin left on his legs right oh yeah
this is a Maze Runner movie where
physics do not exist in the actions have
no consequences also remember when there
were actually mazes in Maze Runner
movies good times zero one Niner be
advised
you've taken on boarders at the rear one
positive to come from this movie is now
I have a new sex role-playing game for
me and the Misses yes as we all know the
dune buggy or whatever the this is has
such maneuverability as to avoid airship
missiles fat and this guy can't shoot
per the strategy should not pay off for
Thomas because the wicked soldier is
clearly have the high ground
that's OB 101 I guess it's possible they
could have timed
all this to exactly where Newt was
hiding out except for the fact that they
couldn't
so there are two cars full of immune
kits instead of simply looking down one
of the many openings in the roofs of
these cars he goes with the absolutely
impossible method to find his friend
it's like horton hears a mean hole but
wait dumber because we are only here for
mean ho the rest of you can go
yourselves swirling fast I'm sure that's
a good excuse it's not that you're
incompetent at your job and that you've
been less than 30 feet behind this Jeep
for probably five or six miles now and
haven't been able to shoot them down wow
that worked well why not make more than
one of them just in case they came from
a different direction and or you could
kill more guys they've all develop their
own traits and skills between films
they're just a computer hacker and a
contortionist away from being able to
rob three casinos in one night the
wicked guys have guns with sights on
them and a better range but sure Thomas
and his trusty peashooter are enough to
suppress these assholes I have got to
listen to a recording of Thomas and his
crew planning this fucking thing out
when we go after the Train we could
we'll definitely send one of their
airships it's imperative that the
airship follows Jorge and Brenda so we
can lead them into a trap
once they send out their ground troops
and we subdue them will sneak someone in
to steal their airship which Jorge
definitely can fly and get there before
Wicked's train guards can cause any
trouble the airship will then lift the
train car to freedom after this is done
has everyone snorted their share of the
confidence cocaine good let's do this so
is the soldier waiting to not have a
good shot to try and kill Vince okay yay
people I'm sure we're in the last movie
which I literally just watched but can't
remember them at all but glad they're
okay
you mean the locate mean hoes yelling in
a sea of shouting people method didn't
work but it seems so foolproof we're
getting the hell out of here we're gonna
go to a place where wicked will never
find you place you can start over even
though the whole premise of the series
is that there isn't anywhere to go they
don't find a cure for the flare may help
you the only reason Brenda is wearing
these pants with a legs if ur and
Jorge's invading her personal space is
to show you the viewer she still has
that crank bite from the last movie I'm
telling you there was just no other way
to remind you of this that all lies on
the moon for I'm we're - what other
location to find out later that wicked
wants to take these kids to a city so
why didn't they already do that in the
last movie we could schedule was
accelerated to the point that Ava Paige
wanted kids immediately so while the
train rides
took us six months to get here I mean
seriously
almost we could do it in with the kid
for six months that did involve taking
them to whatever city they needed to
take them to the last city it was their
whole base of operations but instead of
taking the kids directly from the glade
in the first movie to the last city they
took them to some other remote facility
for some reason for tests but they
surely could have done at the base of
operations and we could have avoided the
Scorch Trials altogether and that would
have made me happy but you can't ask me
to put those kids on the line for one
man you did it in Saving Private Ryan
and nothing bad happened to huh some
asshole was about to do some in the
middle of the night while everyone is
sleeping but some other asshole somehow
knows it and stops them or joins them
cliche also I understand having some
sort of hero complex but how exactly did
Thomas think he was gonna succeed by
going alone luckily the script provided
him with reinforcements this would be
exciting except almost five hours into
this trilogy and I still have no fuckin
clue what these mazes have to do with I
mean at least they're trying something
here this won't just be me no thinking
he's back at the maze but he's actually
somewhere else damn it hey remember the
2014 classic Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yeah this is the exact plot of
that movie right wicked is draining
these mutant teenagers of their blood to
create an antidote to a virus which is
exactly what happened in that movie I
just thought I'd point that out I'm tell
me when the books were published I don't
want to know that but it seems to be
working how was the maze effective
answer one goddamn question movie why
does why a dystopia have to be so
convoluted with mazes and hungers and
divergence yeah good idea
turn on your headlights when you're
several hundred feet inside the tunnel
already taken that's a slug this frypan
have the option to take it any other way
there in a tunnel with a lot of trash to
car obstacles to drive around it needs
to improve his backseat driving skills
okay yeah I mean totally if you only see
one right now that means there's only
one and that's all though will ever be
forever and ever amazing how these
cranks which do nothing but screech and
run haphazardly towards human flesh
managed enough self control for a
stealth-attack this time guys was
Michael Jackson's Thriller always this
beat got the things you love when you're
a kid Brenda and more ax not gonna also
know you gotta love how they plow
through all these cranks and don't even
once think their friends might be in the
middle of all this I guess they could
see them in the fucking dark and also
also you're telling me this loud ass
truck drove through the tunnel and it
didn't attract the attention of one
thing crank in the previous shot that
was clearly a horde of cranks in front
of them and now there's nothing yeah
let's say figured out some other way to
keep the cranks
or award ze Christmas with the Kranks to
high voltage she's gonna be that to him
these movies play the pronoun game to an
annoying degree just say Teresa knew
everyone else would we've never been
this close to a cure we've sacrificed a
lot to get this far
seems like you've wasted the last three
years running kids through mazes but
progress sure why formulate a plan when
just running headfirst into a conflict
is the best policy neither does a maze
runner movie clocking in at 2 hours and
21 minutes but alas here we are you find
out later that these guys are actually
on Thomas is sought which is lucky for
everyone involved since Thomas's friends
ran into some random alcove where these
guys just happened to be Chuck yeah you
know I remember how was that remember
and he was stung when he wasn't stung
and half out of his mind Gally tied
Thomas and Teresa up two poles to be
grief or sacrifices so I think Newt
needs to let Thomas do his thing after
the maze I got picked up by a group
headed to the city they were just
passing by the wicked facility decided
to go in for whatever reason amazingly
found me before I died healed me and we
avoided Wiccans airships all the way
here so that's all you need to know
about the miraculous recovery junior
mint ah let's go to Kinko's now zombie
Goggins is telling thomas this to ensure
that he comes back because he wants to
make sure that if he saves me now he'll
bring the death cure back with him but
after this when the plan is in motion he
allows everyone to go beyond the wall
even though he still doesn't have the
cure so what's the point now you might
be saying zombie Goggins doesn't care
about the cure and just wants to destroy
wicked but the same principles apply
scene does not come back in any way to
the plot of this movie
Jorge plays the Han Solo game to try and
fool one audience member that he's not
going to save the day like he always
does
Hey so in the end these are just more
competently made Resident Evil films
right but somehow worse definitely I'm
secure nee guessing you shanks have
something to do with that and yet none
of those big airships are flying
overhead that Detective Thomas is sensor
earlier so you shithead way in a might
however there was absolutely no reason
to explain what it was before we got
this far also can you believe this Cole
Thomas wanted to go by himself earlier
oh we be right now if his awesome
friends didn't stalk him and tag along I
set out a win and say you're gonna like
him because that's how we succeed in
this world dangle an unknown solution to
people's problems and spring the details
on them when they've gone too far to
object Sooey
they went back they went through all
that trouble so that Gally could show
them the building and
Theresa is working there couldn't have
just told them that well I know is that
wicked must have put me in that maze for
a reason maybe it was literally just so
they could tell the difference between
immunes like you and people like me when
did this asshole get stung or bitten you
think what the character like Newt there
would have been a traumatic scene where
we saw this and maybe there was but I
totally missed it and that's the movies
fault not mine maybe it is my fault but
I don't really care you're going to save
her and you can save so many others
we're just going to have to Clockwork
Orange this out of you every day but
it's for the kids mean home I see yeah
so does Thomas know Theresa schedule at
this point think about how he got here
if he thought she saw him at a crosswalk
and then he disappeared so I guess he
thought she'd be there hoped she'd see
him and then further hope that she would
chase after a phantom bit of a setback
there's nothing we're not used to not
this time the virus is airborne it's
inside the walls hate scenes like this
because it gives new information without
any real context is this a new
development that the virus is airborne
or has it always been that way there's
got to be a reason why everyone in this
town wear surgical mask is she saying
those won't help them anymore as the
virus stronger did he get through the
walls when Thomas and the other snuck
inside during Ava's exposition dump in
the first movie she never explained that
the virus was contracted from animal
bites or from the air so could we know
this Aaron was our last chance anyone
not already infected will be inside of a
month dr. page literally arrested all
her laurels on me no doctor risks
everything on that smaller sample size
mommy's our last treatment I say we show
you that was months ago Thomas that's
not possible
come on Teresa you're a scientist you
should know that they gave her Thomas's
blood and that Thomas is Jesus by now so
frustrating when movies do this mean
what could it be why isn't Brenda a
zombie already
why isn't she's singing cranberries
tunes good thing Wicked's highly secure
headquarters does it require any kind of
ID for their faceless guards or this
plan was cooked from second one that's
fine systems glitching I'll go check it
out this works the vault how do I get in
Kent and Gally gives up super easy he
was ready to cut off Teresa's thumb
earlier but can't put some pressure on a
single guard to find out information
he's not the sloth of a build-up to
finally saving me no makes the three
seasons we had to wait for gin and soon
to reunite on loss seemed like nothing
[Applause]
you know so this movie can go on for
another hour
where did Jensen even come from was he
just waiting beside the elevator door
and if so why wasn't he already walking
in before the doors started closing I
promise
detect you yeah like you protected me
huh what are you doing the same thing
this guy always does ma'am aren't you
used to it by now when the hell does it
stop it stops when we find a cure there
is no god damn sure this is essentially
the second time they're having a
conversation about the magical
properties of Thomas's blood but Theresa
can't figure out how to tell him about
it
without this dickhead flying off the
handle geez how is wicked not figured
out that the good guys stormed this room
a minute ago and took out a bunch of
guards like does anyone even check up on
these people
yeah yell for him that works so great
last time this mother stole ish earlier
but since then he's been tased and
sedated so it's good to see you mean
hose grip stays so strong during all
that not to mention his hiding skills
okay Stu surface tensions aside I guess
that water is deep enough so they don't
crash into the floor at the bottom well
Thomas you've got people all over the
building looking for you and you just
made a huge spectacle by jumping out of
the window into the pool so this really
shouldn't surprise you at all we find
out in a second that this is Gally and
I'm wondering why did he even let it get
this far before shooting the other
guards it won't make much sense and I
barely understand it myself but all you
need to know is that he's alive and this
movie never ends Claire martial law no
one leaves until their fans considering
its already been established that no one
has allowed reentry back into the city
why have you now denied all entry then
why would anyone be leaving my question
is how did they think this plan was
gonna work
she's driving a huge bus it's not like
they can hide in a city with a curfew
patrolled by wicked this was doomed from
the start but it looked like the movie
is telling us it's an unlucky snag
luckily the roadblock didn't happen
earlier than this and it's precisely
where the next part of the plan had to
take place and Wicked's army is a bunch
of incompetent assholes Plus once again
I ask where are the airships this has
zero chance of keeping everyone alive
ever unhurt the conditions in the Sweet
Hereafter we're safer than this give me
a goddamn break at least tell me little
Timmy died or something tell me everyone
survived this I haven't seen a bus this
erect since I accidentally got invited
to that orgy at Jerome Bettis house this
bus has better comedic and dramatic
timing than the majority of the cast
[Music]
Hollywood we need to discuss your
Wilhelm scream choices did Jorge know
where to fly how did he even know they
needed help they were part of the plan
why was Brenda so surprised to see the
airship the problem with the movie where
the heroes don't tell you what the
ultimate plan is and tons of things go
wrong is that when the X market has
happened you have to back up and wonder
who knew what and when wouldn't have
been much better to hear the plan and
have Jorge say if I don't hear from you
it's such-and-such time I'm gonna come
find you location X the weapon did that
does somebody have Godzilla fighting
with them fun fact if you splice this
into the Hunger Games the divergent
series the purge or Cloverfield nobody
can tell the difference okay so is this
the crank coming out of Newt trying to
kill Tomas because I thought cranks were
simply zombies and didn't use weapons
look on the bright side Newt you don't
have to be a part of this movie anymore
excuse me I need to go find some alone
time somewhere in this riot you can say
this too bad wicked didn't figure this
out prior to going on willy nilly and
using the let's put them in mazes and
see what happens strategy okay I don't
know but maybe Janssen should have led
with the gun these missiles could have
killed Thomas and the cure to the flare
virus but who gives it right viva la
revolucion and the revolutionaries
really should have coordinated with the
people who made the attack on this city
possible they're gonna kill the guy with
the cure man god damn it try another
plan man it's obvious they aren't gonna
kill you so why shoot at the guy who can
save everybody with this magic blood and
the one person who can synthesize it has
Game of Thrones here stalks Thomas and
Theresa and we have about 12 minutes
left in the whole series I'm like I know
something was up with that maze trial in
the first movie where the scientists
hoping to discover all we got was some
vague explanation from dr. Paige about
how mean hos blood got more potent but
that whole thing was a bunch of bull
right they endangered the lives of the
people who could save them I can
honestly ran about everything they did
in the Maze Runner but it would require
an hour of writing time miss Julie yeah
how does Thomas know that crack in the
glass would eventually make these glass
doors completely break and if he knows
that how did Janssen not know that they
better get off that roof before there's
CGI to death I tried what I know she's
hot Thomas but come on the power of the
boner can make you forget all your
friends that have perished because of
her actually I don't have a good answer
this well everything seems hopeless so
about time for that airship to show up
Theresa sacrifices herself
God knows why but I think it has
something to do with the fact that
Renda is also in love with Thomas and
because Brenda is 100% good and Theresa
is human with complex beliefs and thinks
about the big picture she's the one
who's got to die I guess Brenda won by
default this is gonna be a good home for
us pretty sure Thomas will find a way to
bat up dear Thomas who duration this is
the first letter I can remember writing
despite that you'll see that my curse of
handwriting is amazing but from that
moment you ran into the maze I knew I
would follow you anywhere which is a
total lie Thomas running into the maze
for the first time was incredibly stupid
and he should have died I think what
Newt meant to say was when I saw you
miraculously emerge from the maze alive
I still hesitated to follow you but this
is my dying letter so get I always knew
you were the guy to follow you know
what's amazing about this rock with dead
people's names on it
nobody shared a first name there wasn't
a John B or a Sarah M no in the future
they figured out how to give nobody the
same name as another person hey smooth
skin you need something I just made my
last payment
what's this war in the heart of nature
why does nature vie with itself the land
contend with the sea this place used to
be off-limits man because some drunk
freshmen fell off
you went right down the middle smacking
his head on every beam it
I'm the Skywalker I'm here to rescue you
every time I'm face was a decision I
closed my eyes and see the same picture
whenever I consider an action I ask
myself well this action help to make
this picture a reality a picture of me
on the Iron Throne
and you by my side
ah no the gone Paul Newman's gonna have
my legs broke all I want is to fight on
the top of the Train let's go get kicked
out of us by now okay stupid
aim for the bushes hey good luck let me
tell you about my best friend